i gotta stress
we're gonna limber up okay okay
everybody's doing it i'm so inflexible
one of the hardest parts of dating is
guessing someone's intentions are they
truly interested in you or are they
looking out for themselves how do you
know when you're being played we created
a game show to find out one bachelor
looking for love will meet five
potential matches i'm in it for love i'm
in it for love i'm in it for love i'm in
it for love i'm in it for love here's
the catch some of them are lying and
trying to win a cash prize can our
bachelor eliminate gold diggers and try
to find a true match or will they get
played this is love or money
are you guys excited
nervous you're nervous
well this is your very handsome bachelor
zach hi i'm zach hi
yes hello i'm zach
i'm 24 i guess i'm from grove city ohio
i'm a filmmaker and little actor and a
kid at heart awesome what do you look
for in a match i look for someone who
can just have as much fun as i can no
matter where ever i go if i go to the
grocery store for milk
we're gonna be there for two hours
underneath your seats you guys have
envelopes and markers you guys can pick
them up and you're gonna write down if
you're in this for love or money
and once you write it down you're locked
in and you cannot change your answer
are you hopeful uh i'm i'm hopeful but
i'm def i'm gullible that's one of the
biggest things and uh yeah everyone's
telling the truth is that why you're
still single
probably
hi guys
hi hello welcome to round one where
you're going to make your first
impression you have 10 minutes starting
now
well disappointed in her because she
lied to me she said she was going to be
by my side this whole time but
i feel like i need the pace like this is
very just like general let's start off
with like a little fun fact we'll go
weirdest thing about you i guess okay so
i can move my chin
without moving my jaw and i don't want
to do it on camera but i guess i will
wait i might be able to do it is it this
that can we do the same thing yes it's
weird as hell everyone everyone thinks
okay um i
uh get paid to larp over summers that's
dope
all right sweet this is going so much
better
okay so you said that you like someone
that's like down to like have fun and
just like have a good time with and i
have
this nice what is this it says down nice
now if anyone wants to go like somewhere
you're just like
yeah i did that last weekend um i like
diving airplanes at the ground at like
200 miles an hour
wow
right now
in the future if we do date then you can
see that happen yeah yeah i'm actually
pre-professionally trained in classical
ballet
among other things
split off do it right now i gotta stress
three steps
we're gonna limber up okay okay
everybody's okay
[Music]
zach
how do you feel feel good uh 10 minutes
flew by super fast it seemed like they
liked you do you think anyone's in it
for the money anyone suss i don't know
if i can honestly say
if i can decide if someone is
maybe you're too busy doing the splits
yeah
zach
are you ready
to eliminate
two of these beautiful women
do you like know who you're going to go
with
i forgot about this next part and i'm
sad yeah we are too
that being said zach you have to
eliminate two
beautiful
limber
girls right now are you ready
by point that's weird
but sorry
nice meeting you it was so nice meeting
you i hate this
when you said that he like wanted
someone that was like more down and like
more spontaneous i don't know i thought
we clicked a little bit more but um i'm
not like pressed about it i'm sorry me
oh yeah no you're good sorry yes yeah
yeah just feeling that rejection i was
like i wonder how my face looks like i
was just like replaying my face and i
was like
okay
this is round two where zach will get to
know his potential matches a little
deeper are you ready zach yes you'll
have five minutes with your potential
match and then i gotta call it quits
you'll get to peel them back like a
banana where are they from yeah how many
boyfriends banana questions all that do
you like bananas are you ready yeah i'll
see ya
hello hi good to meet you one-on-one
good to meet you i'm zach hi i'm ashley
nice to meet you meet you we heard a
plane in the last take and we thought it
was your dive bomb oh yeah i just
stepped out for a hot second
i'm zach again i'm sophie again sophie
sophie ph perfect it's great with z or
ch ch yes zach ch sophie ph yeah i don't
know if it's important but i'm a virgo
oh
scorpio oh god
harping let's get into this because i am
i am quite this is this is a good thing
i was excited that you said that because
that's i feel like that's something that
someone would normally just kind of like
we're going to keep that but that's what
i love about it
yeah i work as a flight instructor now
so i just teach people to fly but i do
competition aerobatics i just do some
like basic little like rolls and loops
i don't do that you get in the car
what's the first first thing i play i've
been replaying olivia rodriguez's entire
album because it's a banger but um my
top three are
bony versus my all-time favorite hiatus
coyote and hosier
i've suppressed it now because my dad
always said like no one must always talk
about that stuff yeah i'm usually in a
graphic tee okay i read a lot of comic
books um i used to watch animals
should i say that but you still watch it
yeah
but i used to i used to be like super
into it like i used to wear like the
shirts and like i knew all of the themes
oh do i just leave this was fun yeah
pleasure good to meet you
bam peace peace nice meeting you i don't
know
zach
hello how did it go round two i actually
really enjoyed round two i enjoy talking
to people you enjoyed peeling the
bananas can you pick out the liars yet
no see i keep okay so i'm gonna be
honest i keep forgetting that part of
this but keep your eye open you don't
want to get your heart hurt get to the
bottom of this banana bottom of the
banana maybe it's an hour but before you
finish that banana yeah you have to
eliminate one person okay
did you guys have fun with zach we did
yeah yeah it felt really natural that
was a lot of fun i like that more than
just facing five people at once yeah
that's valid
well it's about to be two
zack you have to eliminate one girl do
you know who it's going to be
yeah yeah
i hate this i hate this just as much oh
sophie
i'm sorry i know we have the ph and ch
but it was a pleasure
bye
i'm not trying to take it personally or
anything you know um but i hope that
like whatever happens like will be for
the best this is round three where zack
will get more intimate with his
potential match zach are you ready to
get closer to them peel that banana just
a little bit more just a little bit more
figure
a brown banana yeah and you don't want
it i don't like that it's mushy too yeah
it's like ew all right well you have 10
minutes to speed date these ladies and
i'm gonna go over there
enjoy yourself
messed up the couch
welcome to zack's corner welcome to my
living
room it's actually pretty comfortable oh
i'd say so i don't know how to sit
i just like this is the default i'd say
whatever couch you're on that's how you
sit yeah 110 oh just casual awesome so
we have to get personal
nice hello this is all right uh do you
have any questions i guess um
oh
deep rooted
i'm like okay
um first of all do you want your
personal space would you like your hair
there we go there we go all right
perfect i'm not gonna lie
just because i didn't know how to react
like i was like
do you have any fears going into oh
going into relationships yeah
dedication factor is really big for me i
feel like that's something that i
struggle with a bit because like once i
get really into like someone i tend to
dedicate like probably
too much time yeah
how many relationships have you been in
um i've been in about two serious ones
so i only really do serious pretty
guarded too so i think i kind of just
close out people pretty easily which
isn't that's probably why i've only been
into relationships or i don't know and
since i just moved down here like i
really don't know anybody yeah you said
you've uh it's been a month you've been
here right yeah
yeah it's been hard good yeah uh
have you ever been cheated on yes you
have yeah how was that because i don't
like that um it was my first
relationship and so it was kind of like
rough yeah it definitely
like affected me a lot
it's trust issues like
i get worried yeah yeah no i feel like
uh i'm the same way because i was
cheated on two and that stuff that has
repercussions which it hurts dude it
literally it'll affect you for whatever
however long time goes by because i
don't ever want to put someone through
that yeah
i just feel like um
if it's not
sorry wait i like sorry i like lost
track of my thought after that
yeah yeah okay well nice to talk to you
thank you for coming absolutely to my
chair yeah thanks for having me yes
how did it go for you uh it went well to
know someone's fears and stuff like that
about relationships or things they've
went through i think is a big part of if
you do move forward with someone so yeah
are you leaning towards a certain girl
yes
all of our interactions have been very
like relaxed laid back in the sense of
like you are talking to a friend do you
think your choice is in it for love or
money
she i'm gonna be honest i feel like she
there's she's the one that has the
potential that could be in it for money
zach
you're going to have to go with your
heart
and choose who you want to go on another
date with remember
both of them can be in it for love both
could be in it for money or one can be
in it for love and one could be in it
for money
i want to go on a date with you
[Music]
i think it went pretty good um didn't
win
or anything but i think i kind of
made my way in there and did the best i
could did you think you were going to
win i kind of did yeah i felt like we
were really five in on thank you
time to find out if ashley was in it for
love
or for money
zach do you think you're able to dig
deep enough and find out her true
intentions
maybe maybe do you yes
think you made the right choice
no no
well this is love or money
and here is your envelope to reveal what
you chose okay
i'm so sorry it's okay it's okay yeah i
mean let's let's i have to cut you guys
off
you can't ask for his number you can't
ask for his social media okay i just
have to walk you out i'm so sorry
and then i just
does it rain money on me or something
like that'd be cool
[Music]
i typically don't go off of like looks
when i'm like talking to people
initially but um we just you know mesh
well i feel like he was he's really
funny it sounded like you guys were
connecting so well yeah but that
happened after i did that
it's fine it's fine i'll suppress it
it's okay you're fine you're fine
zach you're back you're back and you
don't have a love
just left how i was coming in well i
remember saying i said like definitely i
feel like there's a chance that she was
in it for uh the money but i i don't
feel like sad like i wasn't in the back
room crying i heard a little like
whimpering
but no i i was i think i was like you
know just doing the thing
let's go peel that banana off dude
where's that banana right i think it's
moldy by now
oh man
[Music]